your song closer you say what it came
from is I went to school at Syracuse and
I went to school a bunch of rich kids
and I'm not a rich kid and was like in
awe of the fact that they all like drove
their parents Range Rovers and like
outies and really nice cars it was like
crazy to me what's up guys I'm drew and
I'm Alex we're the chainsmokers and
these are the ten essential items that
we must bring wherever we go that's why
it's essential you must bring six four
dozen insurance Shariah this gonna be on
the cover
[Music]
bring in the first essential lift morale
some sweets yeah
very nice read very nice selection you
get to you know spend enough time with
someone there's very few things that the
other one you're starting to become like
the same person and we pretty chose
sentences sandwiches looks like there's
a great assortment of yeast doughnuts
and cake no no it's very important our
managers a big doughnut guy too so kind
of how we bond then we don't see eye to
eye from bring it back to the donut we
went to Australia once and we shot it
out that was it during that time there
yeah and now every time we go they send
us like 500 Donuts and we get to our
room and there's all there you're named
a doughnut after us yeah the dumbell we
down do not let me down
cheers Cheers oh this is essential kind
of boring but pretty boring but very
essential but you got a lot of different
countries they all have different
outlets why why are they all different
it's annoying
really annoying so any one of these that
house like all these like different like
vlogs on it the European I probably up
to 15 of these in the other way just a
little things people so little things
this turns out it becomes
did you redo obviously ping-pong balls
aren't essential if you've ever needed a
ping-pong ball and you're the guy that
has a ping-pong ball everyone's pretty
thrilled about that Alex like to see how
many of these you can fit in his mouth
at once it's just a thing I can fit
what's my record I think you've put two
two cases right yeah crazy where do they
get to see me in an Italian restaurant
with meatballs
he's very stretchy cheeks oh this is
essential so and explain why we have oh
yeah and only Elmer's crew it's not just
any group but we run the problems in
Europe with this it's on our rider when
we first started touring it was just
oscillate no we just will be going our
green room we just sit there by
ourselves and just have each other but
like as things have gone crazier like
you have more people coming in and
talking to you and some people are great
and some people you don't want to talk
to it all and people are just Punishers
yeah you know and so what I found to be
very therapeutic for the Punishers is I
take it and put it on my hands and rub
it in and then I let it dry and then I
just peel it off and it's like I'll talk
to anybody
Europe they don't get it they think we
like to Huff it or something yeah they
get it's like super glue and it's like
no like a stick yeah like if this is the
brand right here and this is the stuff
[Music]
but bubblicious on this this is another
essential this is for Craig um so
there's nothing like chew gum yeah who
did this
sorry about that not essential this is
an essential essential item a sour patch
just in general really the pinnacle of
all candy
we actually got to stay once the sour
patch house in Austin yeah they're like
sour patch branded houses that they want
like creative people to stay up and have
tons of sour patch design which is good
and we threw a big party and now we're
now allowed to go back we know we didn't
throw oh yeah but it was all who were
concerned we were throwing a party that
they kept sending people over the house
and was like the five of us just like
cooking yeah it was funny no problems
though we still love you sour patch but
the candy is fantastic essential
what is this oh this is this is my dog
okay this is Mushu couldn't be here
my dog Mu Shu is an essential item
obviously we can't fly everywhere with
her but she will come on tour with us
and bus tour and she's in the studio
every day and she's in the studio every
day and she's like a morale emotional
support animal yeah for a really
stressful life finicky music yeah hold
on to that okay so we know this is lame
but we have jewel pods it's for a good
cause
Alex used to smoke cigarettes this is
just quit so he smokes the classic
tobacco flavor which is psychopathy okay
I smoked mango like a normal human being
I used to use snus the tobacco that you
put up here so I think this is a better
alternative for that at least but I
think we're both trying to be jewel free
at some point yeah and not be a classic
chatting shoes yeah those are pretty
essential yeah because if you don't have
shoes and your feet get cold it'll be
hard to work I got the Presto's on I got
the converse off white when you tore
this much you can't go to tapas you got
a pic like you only bring two pairs of
shoes you don't in and then you're like
trying to think like on all the kitchens
like what if we're going somewhere muddy
what if we're going to the beach what if
we're going in there's a so we're gonna
what there's snow there
well how fashionable do I want to look
you know and we usually both wear chucks
yeah like some kind of chuck these just
happened to be off lame jokes yeah yeah
but it's nice with some compliments you
on your shoes good makes me feel smarter
yeah I don't know why oh we got one more
thing I made Craig over here who videos
everything how I come in here come lay
on this table
lay down
yeah perfect this is Craig everybody how
you getting all of him bring them
everywhere we go he films every single
thing we do for better works better for
worse and it's great because we like to
give our fans that like raw inside look
into our lives that we're not vloggers
you know I mean there's new generation
so she's going around doing everything
yourself so Craig here who used to be a
fireman in New York quit his job and now
comes with us everywhere here we are
get yourself a Kraig take this get we
don't want this [ __ ] to get out of here
well your bubblicious he's got both of
those Andy held the camera that's why
you need to crank it so that was it
those are our essential items I hope you
enjoyed that insight into our wonderful
lives if you see us get us some donuts
yeah and some glue